un nutricionista desean estimar el
contenido calórico promedio de las
quesadillas en un restaurante popular
para esto obtiene una muestra aleatoria
de 14 quesadillas y mide su contenido
calórico
la muestra resultó aproximadamente
simétrica con una media de 700 calorías
y una desviación estándar de 50 calorías
con base en la muestra cuál de los
siguientes corresponden a un intervalo
de confianza del 95% para la media del
contenido calórico de estas quesadillas
pausa el vídeo y ver si lo puedes
encontrar bien cuál es la situación aquí
por acá tenemos a la población de
quesadillas que tiene una media para su
contenido calórico el cual el
nutricionista desea calcular pero
desconoce el valor real del parámetro de
la población es decir esta media de la
población
y que toman una muestra de 14
quesadillas
por lo tanto n es igual a 14 y con esta
muestra calcula lo siguiente sabe que la
media de las calorías es de 700 y
también saben que tienen una desviación
estándar de 50 calorías ok
usando estos datos necesitamos construir
un intervalo de confianza del 95% bueno
nuestro intervalo de confianza va a
tener la siguiente forma ya lo hemos
visto antes nuestra media muestral más
menos nuestro valor crítico multiplicado
por la desviación estándar muestral
dividida entre la raíz cuadrada de n
estamos usando un estadístico
pues desconocemos la desviación estándar
poblacional si la conociéramos
utilizaríamos en lugar de esta
desviación estándar muestral nuestra
desviación estándar poblacional que se
denota con sigma además estaríamos
utilizando un estadístico z por aquí en
lugar de un estadístico tema y usaríamos
una distribución zeta sin embargo
estamos usando la desviación estándar de
la muestra por lo que requerimos usar un
estadístico t así que calculamos este
intervalo va a ser la media de la
muestra que ya sabemos que es 700 así
que voy a poner 700
- y ahora hay que saber cuánto vale el
estadístico de la muestra cuál sería el
valor crítico para un intervalo de
confianza del 95% bueno para eso
saquemos nuestra tabla tema pero antes
recuerda que para usar la tabla te
requiere saber los grados de libertad y
los grados de libertad es lo mismo que n
menos 1 como sabemos que la muestra es
de 14 quesadillas entonces n vale 14 y
me quedarían 14 menos 1 lo cual es 3
tienen esto en mente cuando hacemos la
tabla te tenemos 13 grados de libertad
así que vamos a usarlos para buscar en
la tabla te sacamos por aquí nuestra
tabla te veamos el intervalo de
confianza del 95% y 13 grados de
libertad aquí están los grados de
libertad 13 grados de libertad que
determinan este renglón que tenemos aquí
y como requerimos un nivel del 95%
recuerda que si nuestra distribución
voy a dibujar una pequeña por aquí muy
pequeña por aquí si necesitamos un 95%
del área en el centro quiere decir que
tenemos 5% repartido equitativamente en
ambas escuelas por lo que tenemos 2.5
por ciento en cada cola así que hay que
buscar la probabilidad de una cola del
2.5 por ciento aquí lo tenemos la 0.25
es 2.5 por ciento y aquí está este es
nuestro valor crítico 2.160 así que ya
tenemos este término de aquí es más
déjame ponerlo con otro color
a esto le voy a sumar y restar 2.160 que
a su vez multiplica a la desviación
estándar de la muestra que ya sabemos
que es 50 entonces voy a poner 50 esto
dividido a su vez entre la raíz cuadrada
de n
pero en nepal de 14 entonces la raíz
cuadrada de 14 y si observas todas las
opciones tienen 700 en primer lugar 700
700 setecientos 700 por lo tanto lo que
necesitamos saber es nuestro margen de
error esta parte de aquí y para eso voy
a sacar la calculadora tengo 2.160 2.160
lo podría dejar como 2 puntos 16 pero
bueno para que lo veas completo esto que
va a multiplicar
50 y esto a su vez está dividido entre
la raíz cuadrada de 14 ok esto me va a
dar 28 puntos 86 déjame escribirlo todo
esto me va a dar 28 puntos 86
aproximadamente parece que necesitamos
unas fanfarrias por aquí porque al ver
las opciones si redondeamos a la décima
más cercana puedes ver que esta es la
opción correcta 700 más menos 28.9
porque bueno estos aproximadamente 28
puntos 86 y esto es aproximadamente 28.9
así que en efecto esta es la opción
correcta aquí lo tenemos ya hemos
construido nuestro intervalo de
confianza del 95 por ciento ahora hay
dos cosas importantes que quiero
mencionar
es este un intervalo de confianza válido
es decir hemos cumplido las condiciones
que le den validez para eso tenemos que
preguntarnos lo siguiente primero
tomamos una muestra aleatoria y bueno
esto nos lo dicen para esto obtienen una
muestra aleatoria de 14 que sabías por
lo tanto vamos a marcar que están si se
cumple la segunda es es la distribución
muestral aproximadamente normal si
tomáramos una muestra de tamaño mayor o
igual a 30 así lo serían pero aquí la
muestra es de 14 de 14 quesadillas sin
embargo nos dicen que la distribución de
nuestra muestra fue aproximadamente
simétrica aquí está la clave no tiene
valores atípicos entonces podemos
suponer que cumplen esta condición de
normalidad
y la última condición es la condición de
independencia en este caso se cumplirían
si tomáramos una muestra con reemplazo
lo cual no parece que así sea al no
muestra algún reemplazo esto tiene que
ser menor o igual que el 10% de la
población de quesadillas y vamos a
suponer que van a preparar más de 140
quesadillas en este restaurante por lo
que consideró que también cumplimos esta
condición de independencia así que al
cumplir estas tres condiciones
este es un intervalo de confianza válido
y ya está lo hemos encontrado así que
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo